موجز الاخبار على قناه الجزيره اهلا بكم
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
ثلاثه فلسطينيين هو اصابه اخرين برصاص
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه خلال اقتحامها
مدينه جنين بالضفه الغربيه وقال شهود عيان
الاحتلال اطلق النار على الشهداء الثلاثه
قرب الميدان الرئيسي لجنينه بينما ظهرت
اشتباكات مسلحه مع مقاومين فلسطينيين
خمسه وعشرين شخص بينهم جنود سابقون ينتمون
الى جماعه من اقصى اليمين بتهمه لاعداد
لاسقاط الدوله
دكتور ليه
يا قائد ما يعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
مظلومه عبدي يا رفضه المقترح الروسي
تسليما قوات النظام المناطق الحدوديه مع
تركيا او تفكيك قوته لتجنيب المنطقه عمليه
عسكريه تركيه
قناه مصادر تركيه للجزيره ان وفد روسيا
برئاسه المبعوث الروسي الى سوريا يتوجه
الى انقره لمناقشه الخيارات شمالي سوريا
من جانبها كذا وزير الخارجيه الروسي سر
الى فروض انا بلاده مهتمه بعمليه استئناف
الحوار بين تركيا وسوريا على اساس اتفاقنا
والذي يمنح انقره حق التدخل في سوريا
لحمايه امنها
اعلنت قوه المهام المشتركه تابعه للتحالف
الدولي التزام التحالف بدعم من وصفهم به
شركائه فيما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه
وسكان الشمالي شرقي سوريا وقال منسق
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان الولايات
المتحده ترفض العمليه التركيه البريه
المرتقبه في شمال سوريا
رغم الانقسامات الكبيره بشان ذلك
في المقابل قال الرئيس الروسي الذي ميرفت
ان خطر الحرب النوويه اخذ في التصاعد لكنه
اكد ان الاستراتيجيه النوويه الروسيه تعمل
على مبدا الرد وان بلاده تنظر الى اسلحه
الدمار الشامل باعتبارها اسلحه دفاعي
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
على دعم الجيش الاوكراني بكل ما يحتاجه
للدفاع عن بلاده لكنها لا تشجع اوكرانيا
على تنفيذ ضربات داخل روسيا
ادت دينا ابو الورد نائبه رئيس بيرو بيدرو
كاستيو اليمين الدستوريه رئيس انتقاليه
للبلاد في عقاب قرار البرلمان عزل الرئيس
كاستيه وبيتهم الفساد والخيانه وتعاهدت
بتشكيلي حكومه وطنيه جامعه ودعت الى هدنه
سياسيه لتجاوز الازمه التي تشهدها البلاد
قد سارع اثار الرئيس اليسرى كاسيو الى
التظاهره امام البرلمان تايدا
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]